you
Nietzsche talking about the European
state of mind at the end of the 19th
century so Nietzsche says well we're in
this terrible situation right
God is dead we've killed them what does
that mean well we've taken our evolved
metaphysics which structures our moral
viewpoint and under minded by rational
criticism a peculiar move
philosophically because it was never
established on rational grounds anyways
we've undermined it rationally and
replaced it with well nothing nothing
what's the consequence of that well he
outlines that here of what is great one
must either be silent or speak with
greatness and you can think about this
as a prophecy on the events of World War
one and World War two and the Gulag
Archipelago and the 60 million people
dead in the Soviet Union and the whole
unfolding of 20th century history and
the great ideological battles that
characterize that unfolding so this is
something Nietzsche sees coming and
knows why he says of what is great one
must either be silent or speak with
greatness with greatness
so that means cynically and with
innocence what I relate is the history
of the next two centuries I described
what is coming what can no longer come
differently the advent of nihilism right
the belief in nothing
our whole European culture is moving for
some time now with a tortured tension
that's growing from decade to decade as
towards a catastrophe restlessly
violently headlong like a river that
wants to reach the end that no longer
reflects it's afraid to reflect he that
speaks here has conversely done nothing
so far but to reflect as a philosopher
and solitary by instinct who has found
his advantage in standing aside outside
why is the advent of nihilism become
necessary because the values we've had
hitherto thus draw their final
consequence because nihilism represents
the ultimate logical conclusion of our
great values and ideals because we must
experience nihilism before we can find
out what value these values really have
we require at some time new values
nihilism stands at the door whence comes
this uncanny estuve all guests nihilism
right your beliefs are undermined once
what's the consequence of that
well one consequence is the belief is
undermined the other consequence is more
metaphysical which is fooled once you no
longer have the belief but maybe it's
even worse than that because human
beings can generalise fooled once you
never have any you no longer have any
belief in beliefs which mean you say
something like this I don't care what
you think doesn't matter what you think
the world is such a terrible place that
no interpretation whatsoever can
possibly suffice that's nihilism no
meaning system whatsoever can possibly
suffice well what's the flaw well the
flaw is well of course no system of
coherent belief can suffice because most
of the world's transcendent you can't
encapsulate everything that is in your
sphere of belief and what you might say
that is that if you ever believe that
what you believe is what should support
you the facts you knows say or the
interpretation you place in the world
then your faith is badly misplaced you
don't believe in what you believe you
believe in something that's deeper than
that
and so then you see what's wrong with
Tolstoy right and Tolstoy story and
Tolstoy says accounting for his collapse
in the stability of Christian belief he
said this all happened this collapse of
my belief when I was not yet fifty years
old I should have been considered a
completely happy man
I had a good loving beloved wife fine
children and a large estate growing and
expanding without any effort on my part
I was respected by friends and
acquaintances praised by strangers and
could claim a certain renown I was not
physically nor mentally unhealthy on the
contrary I enjoyed a physical and mental
vigour I had rarely encountered among
others my age I could keep up with the
peasants working in the fields and work
eight and ten hours at a stretch without
suffering any after-effects from the
strain and in such a state of affairs I
came to a point where I could not live
and even though I feared death I had to
employ ruses
myself to keep from committing suicide
it was as though I had lived a little
wandered a little until I came to a
precipice and I clearly saw that there
was nothing ahead except rune and there
was no stopping or turning back no
closing my eyes so that I would not see
that there was nothing ahead except the
deception of life and of happiness and
of the reality of suffering and death of
complete annihilation
I grew sick of life some irresistible
force was leading me to somehow get rid
of it this thought was such a temptation
that I had to use cunning against myself
in order not to go through with it
and there I was a fortunate man carrying
a rope from my room where I was alone
every night as I undressed so that I
would not hang myself from the beam
between the closets and I quit going
hunting with a gun so that I would not
be too easily tempted to rid myself of
life I myself did not know what I wanted
was afraid of life I struggled to get
rid of it yet I hope for something from
it my position was terrible I knew that
I could find nothing in the way of
rational knowledge except a denial of
life and in faith I could find nothing
except a denial of reason and for me
this was even more impossible than a
denial of life I myself according to
rational knowledge at falled that life
is evil and people know it I describe my
spiritual condition of myself in this
way my life is some kind of stupid and
evil practical joke that someone is
playing on me in spite of the fact that
I did not acknowledge the existence of
any someone who might have created me
the notion that someone brought me into
the world as a stupid and evil joke
seemed to be the most natural way to
describe my condition I could not be
deceived all is vanity happy as he who
has never been born
death is better than life we must rid
ourselves of life having realized all
the stupidity of the joke that is being
played on us
and seeing that the blessings of the
Dead are greater than those of the
living and that is better not to exist
the strong act and put an end to this
stupid joke and they use any means of
doing it a rope around the neck water a
knife in the heart or a train now the
interesting thing about this I think is
first of all a Russian wrote it and
second of all was written in the late
1900s and even more particularly is that
you note that when the strong act using
a rope around the neck water a knife in
the heart and a train well Tolstoy is
talking about suicide but there's no
necessary reason to presume that this
should only be violence engendered
against the self right if life is a
stupid and evil joke then what's
stopping you from benevolently putting
an end to the suffering of others right
benevolently in theory at least well you
know that's one perspective right but
then there's always the perspective of
the lady who went to see the
psychiatrist in TS Eliot's poem which is
well if when your eyes are open life
appears as nothing but suffering and
pain to you it could be that that is how
life is but it could also be that
there's something wrong with the way
that you're looking at the world and in
some ways that's a much more humble
perspective right because the
alternative as well I know what's going
on and I just look out there and there's
the world and I'm pretty much got it
like I know what it means and what it
means is pointless suffering and pain
and that's my model and I don't see any
reason to question it but then the
alternative is well wait a second
there's always the possibility that I
don't know absolutely everything in this
final and horrible judgement that I'm
placing on the conditions of existence
could conceivably be misplaced given the
sort of presumptuousness of the claim
right I'm in a position to render final
judgement on the moral value of
existence as such it seems to me
reasonable to presume that that's not
the kind of statement that you should
easily make and I remember when George
Bush launched his most recent war the
initial terminology I think this was for
the Afghanistan battle was operation
infinite justice but he retracted that
phrase after a number of religious
leaders objected to its kind of
presumptuousness which I thought was
quite reasonable because infinite
justice is something that most people
should probably not hope for right
because you never know precisely what
infinite justice means because it might
just mean that every bloody mistake
you've ever
our maid you're going to pay for and I
suppose that would be just as applicable
to george w bush as it would to anybody
else and then milton again describes the
development of this adversarial spirit
he says first pride pride and worse
ambition threw me down at satan's lament
when he's in hell and Milton's
description of Hell is extremely
interesting he said the reason that hell
is characterized by its structure is not
so much because of its its nature
precisely it's because of its distance
from the good so the farther you are
away say from what constitutes the good
the more suffering is the more suffering
is endemic to that state so it's it's
the distance away from something that
constitutes the suffering and then
Milton says it's very interesting to do
an analysis of Satan's character and the
notion of Hell per se because how in the
world can you reconcile the idea of a
good God with the notion of this
continual suffering and so Milton says
well Satan can step out of hell in one
moment all he has to do is meant that he
was wrong and that's the one thing that
he will not do under any circumstances
whatsoever so then we put one more twist
on the story we say something like this
okay we already know that part of the
reason that people have belief systems
is so that they can structure their
interactions with the world it's a tool
box say we're playing a game we share
the rules that's fine we can cooperate
with one another it could be other than
it is but it's the way it is and it
works for us that's fine there's nothing
absolute about it except that a
structure like that's necessary now
whenever there's a threat to that shared
view of the world well then we're afraid
and for good reason and and it's not
surprising under those circumstances
that we fight to defend what we've made
ours but then you say say you adopt this
perspective right and it's this vengeful
desire to wreak havoc that extends
beyond other individuals and Beyond
society even to the structure of
experience as such and then you think
well what's the best mask for that and
how do these two processes sort of
interact do you think well the most
efficient way to do terrible things is
to mask them with the highest order
morality and that's precisely what the
total
terian does so that way he gets to have
his cake and eat it too he's perfectly
well protected from apprehension of the
world because his belief system is
complete plus his underground
motivations which is this constant
desire for revenge confined their
expression within the totalitarian
structure and remain invisible even to
himself so he can say to himself well
the reason I threw all those farmers out
of their house in 1920 and stalled their
soup and their food and their
grandmother's blankets and everything
they'd work to own was because I was
building the socialist paradise right
and it was a good thing for me to go
into that house and not a bad thing and
as long as he believes that or acts as
if he believes that then he can look in
the mirror without screaming and there's
no recognition whatsoever of precisely
the sort of game that he's involved in
so he has it both ways right he can do
everything terrible that he always
dreams of doing and consider himself not
only good but good even at a higher
level than the people that he was
actually afflicting and of course that's
just standard description of what
happened in the Soviet Union Nietzsche
says I love this definition of morality
is the most cynical thing Nietzsche ever
said I think the idiosyncrasy of
decadence with the ulterior motive of
revenge against elf against life
successfully I attach value to this
definition so will why be an ideologue
well it's a good way to simplify the
world right it's a procrustean bed you
just chop off everything that doesn't
fit then you don't have to think right
so that's good because thinking is
difficult and it's trouble someone that
takes courage and so forth to transform
chaos into orders no trivial matter and
if it's all ordered for you well then
there's really nothing left for you to
do but then Nietzsche goes even below
that he says yeah well there's more to
the story than that isn't there it's
like once you got this little
procrustean bed all arranged for your
enemies then you can you can allow your
most base vengeful instincts full flow
by just continually chopping people so
they fit
and you do it all the while but well
saying well it's obviously the best
thing that could possibly be done and so
then you look at Stella and say because
not everybody who's adopted a vengeful
tack on existence is sort of like the
archetype of vengefulness or adversarial
spirit but you get now and then the
people like Stella who are good counter
examples say to the people like Gandhi
and so stones very instructive and so we
could start by looking at what he did in
the Ukraine so at the end of 1929 the
Kremlin decreed that millions of
peasants from individually owned farms
would be forced into agricultural
collectives or kolkhozes seen in the
eyes of the Politburo has pliant
providers of Soviet agricultural needs
in defiance of the facts so they they
all had just hammered out an appropriate
Marxist terminology to explain what was
going on throughout grain producing
areas it was said resistance to this
scientific scheme was being organized by
so-called rich peasants or cool acts
with his customary brutality therefore
Stellan decreed the liquidation of the
kulaks as a class stellen liked this
idea of like group guilt that was a
major theme for Stalin like that man I
really didn't have to ever pay attention
to you as an individual I could just
decide if you were a doctor engineer or
a Kulak her a German or whatever ethnic
racial or educational division happened
to characterize my particular target at
the time and didn't matter if you were
guilty as an individual that whole
notion never even obtained it was class
guilt that mattered and if you were in
one of those classes well we were better
without you and of course the nature of
the class just changed constantly but it
was perfectly logical thing to think if
you believed in like historical
determinism if your parents were rich
burgeois what was the probability that
you're going to be a useful part of the
workers collective be easier just to get
rid of you ahead of time so you didn't
cause too much trouble so then you think
about these cool acts rich peasants well
who are these people like when we get
down to the individual level so you go
on a village village was full of serfs
like not 40 years before so these are
people just struggling out of the
util society right and you got some
people in there who've managed to be
successful enough as farmers which is no
easy thing to like have a house and
maybe hire one person and you know maybe
have a little extra food in the larder
and a few kind of material possessions
so these are successful people and so
you could say well they're the ones that
actually knew how to farm it's one
theory or you could say the reason they
had all this stuff was because they
stalled it from all the other people
right and then you think okay so I march
into town I'm a Soviet revolutionary and
I say hey guys you know those rich
people they stole everything they have
from you and then you think okay which
of you guys is going to listen to that
well it's not going to be the sort of
struggling people just underneath them
who are really trying to get ahead right
because that's where they're hoping to
get it's going to be the resentful and
revengeful few who think well the world
is fundamentally unfair and it's obvious
that those sons of [ __ ] got what they
want by stealing it from me and here it
turns out that if I just go down the
street and steal it back well not only
not only am I allowed to do that but
according to this new and emergent
ideology man that's the best thing I
could possibly do so then multiply that
story by several million participants
and you have like the first five years
of the Soviet empire and so what do we
have there the result was a catastrophic
onslaught on millions of peasant
households at first party activists and
local officials read bullies right
brutalized peasants forcing them to
surrender their homesteads and their
possessions deportations arrests and
killings soon followed as terror
generalized the violence mounted to
full-scale rebellion in various places
with regular troops engaged for months
for example suppressing peasant
uprisings resistance took various forms
usually reflecting the hopeless
desperate anguish of a doomed population
in the Ukraine there are even women's
rebellions spontaneous uprisings of
peasant women who attack the local
kolkhozes to bet demand the return of
confiscated farm products with a
colossal impact on the Soviet economy
peasants slaughtered their animals by
the millions rather than see them seized
for two years the fighting raged as the
dreadful process of D cool
zatia continued stellen order to further
assault on the recalcitrant peasantry
what conquest calls the terror Famine of
1932 Moscow rights conquest it's from a
book called the harvest of sorrow
knowingly decreed grain procurements
from the Ukraine and elsewhere exceeding
by far with the local population could
produce which meant that everyone who
lived there was forced and ordered to
deliver more grain than they had ever
grown communist brigades roamed the
countryside forcing agriculturalists to
discourage the little they had being
able to produce under conditions of
severe dislocation grain sat unused in
state reserves while the local
population starved this is from wisdom
apocryphal biblical writings for they
reasoned unsound Lee saying to
themselves short and sorrowful is our
life and there is no remedy when a man
comes to his end and no one has been
known to return from Hades because we
were born by mere chance and hereafter
we shall be as though we had never been
because the breath in our nostrils is
smoke and reason a spark kindled by the
beating of our hearts when it is
extinguished the body will turn to ashes
and the spirit will dissolve like empty
air our name will be forgotten in time
and no one will remember our works our
life will pass away like the traces of a
cloud and be scattered like mist that is
chased by the Rays of the Sun and
overcome by its heat for our allotted
time is the passing of the shadow and
there's no return from our death because
it is sealed up and no one turns back so
a piece of writing thousands of years
old and so Nietzsche says at the end of
the 1900s while rationality undermines
our faith in religion but you have a
piece of writing too from more than
2,000 years ago that says look what is
it about being alive it's short and
there's nothing to it
right our thoughts are biologically
produced and when we die there's nothing
left well that's a very modern thought
yep it was expressed thousands of years
ago so you know I think merely from
observing that that the crisis of faith
that characterizes modern society is a
reflection of the permanent crisis of
faith that characterizes human being
what's happening with the totalitarian
well the totalitarian is afraid of the
unknown for good for good reason I mean
and he's very interested in sustaining
his own belief structure and the
combination of those two things can
start off trivially is that the more
you're convinced that you have to
maintain the stability of your current
belief structure the more afraid you are
of good of anything that's unknown and
the more afraid you are of anything
that's unknown the less likely you are
to go out and explore it and then the
less likely you already go out and
explore it the weaker you get because
you stop gathering information and then
the weaker you get the more necessary it
is that you have to have this frame of
reference and it has to remain intact
and this sort of thing starts to cycle
and cycle so you undermine your own
sense of your own autonomy and ability
and you make yourself more and more a
rigid tool of the propagandistic system
and you're more and more adopt the
stance of enmity towards anything you
don't understand and that's a spiral
that goes rapidly downhill right rapidly
into a state that's characterized by
complete internal chaos and I think
that's a good definition of what is
meant in metaphysical language by hell
right hell is a bottomless pit why well
I don't care how bad things are for you
or around you there's always some bloody
thing you could do to make it worse
right there's always some suffering you
can extend to others there's always some
bit of stubbornness or rejection that
you can pull off that'll make your
already terrible situation worse right
so there's no bottom and that seems to
me to be right if you do just a cursory
historical analysis no matter what
terrible account you can come across
with regards to say concentration camp
brutality in some other book there's
some worse story right limited only by
the absolute the absolute ends of the
most brutal form of imagination all a
consequence I think of this process
right and you can't really say what
causes it because on the one hand
there's cowardice and lack of faith
right anything I don't understand
cowardice pride in lack of faith
anything I don't understand doesn't
exist plus I'm not the person to
confront it anyways right that's the
lack of faith
each of those things feeds into the
other and it's very difficult to say
where it starts the thing that's kind of
interesting about these self referential
processes is that they don't have to
start dramatically like the loop can
start very very small and it picks up
speed very very rapidly so you imagine
you're speaking into a tape recorder and
the speakers on you get too close to the
speaker with the microphone and you get
some feedback and if you bring the
microphone a little closer the feedback
develops more and more intensely it can
blow up the whole system doesn't have to
start dramatically to move forward very
very rapidly and what that means at
least in principle is that even small
mistakes anywhere along this circle can
start the development of precisely this
kind of spiral and so you say well
people do people need to be abused to
become totalitarian well the answer to
that is no because everyone's being
abused sufficiently by some occurrences
in their life to justify taking a
negative tack on the nature of
experience you say well how cowardly do
you have to be in order to run away from
things and you think well not back
cowardly because under most
circumstances your life is characterized
by sins of omission right it's there are
things you left undone and like I just
exactly how rigid do you want your
belief systems to be and you say well I
like them to be stable because without
that stability then I'm terrified and
then you can say well fair enough but
that's all a sign of a kind of
existential weakness and then if social
circumstances come around and give your
life a good tweak say like they did with
the Germans prior to World War two you
just never know what side you're going
to end up one and so all these little
tiny mistakes you know mistakes that I
think are marked by your own conscious
are precisely that leads you down this
terrible path and if you think well no
that can't be right
well then you have to remember that in
these processes say of decolonization
and that immense wave of deaths that
characterized the Soviet Union and Nazi
Germany most people were involved and if
they weren't involved in direct acts of
commission they were absolutely involved
in direct acts of
mission right they knew but they didn't
say anything
well classically sins of commission are
regarded as much more evil say than sins
of omission but I actually think that's
backwards the sins of omission are worse
because every time you walk away and
what do you do when you walk away from a
Nazi what are you walking away from well
we know what you're walking away from
right if you're walking away from a
domain that's likely to expand into
something that's completely
undifferentiated it's going to happen so
then I think to end this something like
this we look for economic reasons to
explain great terrible acts right we
look for social reasons we look for
political reasons but we have
Nietzsche's observation which is
something like this I don't care whether
or not your life's being characterized
by suffering and deprivation the mere
fact of suffering and deprivation does
not allow you to draw a particular
conclusion you can't say that there's a
causal path between economic deprivation
say in the rise of a totalitarian state
because any events susceptible to
multiple interpretations well how do
these states come about well I think
well we look for political and economic
and social reasons because that's the
easiest place to look right if you
ratchet up the level of description to
social forces that are beyond your
control then you never have to worry
about what it is that you're doing or
not doing that's actually causing this
sort of thing but I think if you look at
the historical record especially if you
look at it from a mythological
perspective the stories basically clear
and it goes something like this every
time you make a mistake that you know is
a mistake and you don't fix it the world
moves more towards that and it might be
trivial maybe but it might not be so you
look at Adolf Eichmann for example who
is the little bureaucrat who planned the
final solution and you find out he's
just your little ratty guy right you see
him in a bar you don't even notice him
he's a negligible nobody but he's the
guy who planned the final solution he
was a normal person
I mean maybe even slightly less than
normal right he was no monster he wasn't
the sort of person you'd remark on if
you saw him precisely the opposite
invisible quiet unassuming presuming no
doubt that at least until he was
arrested that he was just doing what he
was told and that was just fine
you